[Música]
ya son al menos 40 las personas
fallecidas por causa de la tormenta
helio que ha afectado gran parte de
Estados Unidos en el estado de Nueva
York el más afectado por la tormenta al
menos 28 personas perdieron la vida
una serie de explosivos fueron
encontrados en Brasilia la capital
brasileña se trata del Tercer ataque
frustrado por la policía días previos a
la investidura del nuevo presidente Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva las autoridades
afirmaron que garantizarán la seguridad
en la toma de Posesión el primero de
enero
y triunfó el poliamor en Colombia un
fallo histórico de la Corte Suprema
obligó el pago de la pensión de
sobrevivencia a dos personas vinculadas
a una relación estable de cuatro
personas la decisión de la justicia
senta un nuevo precedente en la
conservadora sociedad colombiana
Hola Bienvenidos a este informativo de
France 24 en el que hacemos énfasis en
los temas del continente americano vamos
a comenzar en Estados Unidos porque ya
son cerca de 40 las personas que han
fallecido a causa del paso de la
tormenta Elliot que ha afectado a gran
parte del país con fuertes vientos
Nevadas y bajas temperaturas las
condiciones climáticas extremas
afectaron cerca del 60% de la población
de todo el país justamente en las
celebraciones de Navidad el estado de
Nueva York es el más afectado por estas
condiciones más detalles de la situación
en el reporte de Rafael Pérez
continuará el clima extremo en Nueva
York así lo hizo saber la gobernadora
del estado kaydy hocket que pidió se
declare el norte del estado como zona
catastrófica cualquiera que declare
Victoria y afirme que esto se acabó es
demasiado pronto para afirmar que esto
está por terminar tal vez la severidad
no sea la misma y este momento no sea
tan malo como lo ha sido en los últimos
días pero sigue siendo un problema
peligroso para estar afuera es la peor
tormenta que afecta el estado desde 1977
cuando un evento similar mató a casi 30
personas el comisionado de policía en
Búfalo se refirió al orden interno de su
territorio
estamos al tanto de los informes de
saqueos hemos visto algo de eso en redes
sociales nuestros oficiales han
respondido a varios informes hemos
realizado algunos arrestos hemos
intervenido en algunos de ellos las
imágenes se ratifican la fuerza de la
ventisca del siglo como ha sido
calificada por las autoridades la
guardia nacional se encuentra en la
localidad de Búfalo que bordea el lago
Eric uno de los sitios más afectados
para trabajar en el rescate de personas
atrapadas por la nieve miles de vuelos
fueron cancelados este fin de semana
festivo en todo Estados Unidos en el que
millones de personas se movilizaban para
festejar la Navidad La tempestad provocó
que al menos el 60% de la población
estadounidense estuviese bajo alerta por
el clima y más de un millón de personas
se quedaran sin energía eléctrica
la policía brasileña encontró una serie
de explosivos A las afueras de la
capital la ciudad de Brasilia Este es el
tercer intento de atentado frustrado
tras tan solo unos días antes de la toma
de investidura del presidente electo
Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva el ministro
del interior entrante dijo que las
autoridades van a garantizar la
seguridad para el evento del primero de
enero al cual se espera asistan unas
300.000 personas Andrés triviño nos
amplía
Brasil se encuentra en alerta máxima a
unos días de la investidura de Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva como nuevo
presidente del país sudamericano la
policía desactivó una serie de
explosivos encontrados A las afueras de
Brasilia
Esta no es una acción individual y no lo
permitiremos en Brasil
y no es el primer hecho similar un día
antes un hombre fue detenido cuando
intentaba detonar un artefacto explosivo
en el aeropuerto de la capital brasileña
de manera casi paralela un empresario
Fue capturado tras confesar que había
plantado una bomba dentro de un camión
cisterna de combustible para provocar
caos e impedir la toma de posesión de
Lula el primero de enero en la cual
participarán unas 300.000 personas
incluyendo varios jefes de estado
desde que líder progresista fue elegido
para su tercer mandato en octubre los
grupos bolsonaristas más radicales se
han concentrado frente a cuarteles del
ejército pidiendo un golpe de estado que
evite la investidura de Lula
debemos anticiparnos a ciertos actos
porque no puede haber un vacío de poder
esto no va a pasar en la madrugada del
primero de enero vamos a tomar medidas
para que no se dé esta situación de
inestabilidad
también el Ministerio prevé una nueva
regulación para los clubes de tiro los
cuales se han incrementado desde 2019
según señalan las autoridades
en Perú a medida que las manifestaciones
que han dejado hasta ahora 35 fallecidos
comienzan a apaciguarse los comerciantes
peruanos muchos de ellos informales
resisten a la inestabilidad política y a
la corrupción manteniendo a flote la
economía de la nación andina que parece
indemne a esta crisis Marina sardinha
tiene los detalles
una economía que resiste a las numerosas
crisis políticas la agitación en las
calles de Perú de las últimas semanas no
detiene a los vendedores ambulantes como
Edgar uno de los 60.000 emolienteros del
país como se conoce a este comercio
informal de acá vivimos Entonces si un
día tú no trabajas prácticamente
Entonces como sea Tenemos que trabajar
así aunque sea aunque salga a llamarse 9
de marzo lo que sea Tenemos que trabajar
a medida que las manifestaciones se van
a apaciguando los comercios aprovechan
el último arrean de la campaña navideña
con cierto temor a que se revivan las
marchas y perjudiquen sus sustentos
económicos a la venta como era
anteriormente no por toda esta situación
sinceramente
esta situación nos ha afectado bastante
y estamos en riesgo también de que el
empresario que es propietario de esta
tienda también de que pueda cerrar no y
nos puedan despedir el trabajo Perú
tiene la segunda mejor clasificación de
riesgo de la región por detrás de Chile
las autoridades locales y una economía
que creció una tasa promedio anual del
3,8% el último siglo no todo el mundo
nos ha visto desde donde han estado como
un país que ha salido adelante en todo
no porque tenemos este comida tenemos
turismo tenemos la cultura perdón y
entonces volver a bajar a eso a
nuevamente hacer cero no creo que no se
puede ya si bien la economía peruana se
mantiene a flote y batalla con la
corrupción política la sociedad todavía
tiene que lidiar con la constante
inestabilidad política que deja seis
presidentes en los últimos cinco años
en Colombia un fallo histórico de la
Corte Suprema reconoció el poliamor y
obligó el pago de la pensión de
sobrevivencia a dos personas vinculadas
a una relación de cuatro personas de
manera permanente el fallo admitió la
posibilidad de que personas que ostenten
la calidad de compañeros o compañeras
permanentes que pueden ser de dos o más
no importa el número pueden recibir los
pagos de la pensión vamos a conversar
con Manuel José Bermúdez Andrade uno de
los viudos de esta relación y
beneficiado con este fallo y nos explicó
Cuál fue el argumento que convenció
finalmente a la corte para llegar a este
fallo histórico
el argumento es muy simple y es el amor
y es la convivencia la ley exige techo
lecho y mesa y nosotros pudimos
comprobar que durante diez años con Alex
los tres los cuatro tuvimos
techo lecho y mesa y mucho amor Entonces
ahí no había ninguna discusión bueno así
mismo le preguntamos y le parece que no
hay una sintonía entre la apertura de la
ley colombiana para las parejas del
mismo sexo y para las parejas o grupos
amorosos de más de una persona o dos y
la conservadora sociedad colombiana que
piensa él
sí tenemos Incluso un congreso muy
cerrado muy conservador Pero
afortunadamente esto es un asunto legal
es un asunto de la ley constitucional Y
entonces Desde esa perspectiva
independientemente de que la gente le
guste o no todos los logros que hemos
tenido al margen de la Constitución
Perdón al margen de ese congreso godo se
tienen que sostener porque no hay otra
posibilidad distinta de entender que
somos una familia como cualquiera otra
familia Cada persona tiene derecho a
tener una familia esté constituida como
este constituida somos familia así de
simple y entonces se tienen que acomodar
a que es una norma constitucional la
protección de la familia
en otros temas comenzó oficialmente la
edición número 65 de la feria de Cali
reconocida internacionalmente como la
capital Mundial de la salsa la
celebración que se extenderá hasta el 30
de diciembre Allí se espera que asistan
uno coma cinco millones de visitantes
que esperan que lleguen hasta la Ciudad
de Cali para ser testigos de los
diferentes eventos entre los que
participarán reconocidas orquestas de
salsa como el Grupo Niche y Guayacán
Orquesta entre otros artistas invitados
además unos 2000 bailarines de las
principales escuelas de salsa estuvieron
presentes en la inauguración de la feria
en el tradicional salsódromo con un poco
de salsa desde la llamada sucursal del
cielo cerramos este informativo de
France 24
[Música]